good afternoon or good early evening my
name my name is David thorburn I'm a
professor of literature and the director
of the MIT Communications Forum it's my
pleasure as Forum director to thank the
KN Foundation comparative media studies
uh and the media lab for uh this very
exciting collaboration that we've just
begun The Forum is very happy to to play
a a small role in this collaboration we
feel that this series on Civic media uh
is is uh going to do very interesting
things not only within our own Community
which is important I think it's going to
be a very import important discourse for
MIT folks but especially out Beyond MIT
and and the Forum is proud of its of its
role as a collect collaborator in
sponsoring the most public of the events
connected to the night Knight Foundation
Grant uh today's forum is the second in
what we hope will be a very rich
distinctive series that will run over
the next several
semesters uh before I before I introduce
today's moderator and that will complete
my obligations for today I I have two
other tasks I'd like to uh take care of
one is to remind you about next week you
can see the event that's listed on our
on our uh website for next week uh this
is a particularly interesting time for a
discussion about television as some of
you may know because of the strike that
has just occurred and my hope is that uh
we will be able to get these writer
producers who are really caught in a
very interesting U pickle right now to
talk a bit about the uh circumstances of
the writer in Hollywood and the effects
uh on on on the television industry
especially of the writer strike what
some of the issues are behind it and I I
think it's also important to remind
folks who who might have some skepticism
uh from certain angles about material of
this sort that that that apart from the
astonishing success of Heroes as a
popular text and uh uh it it is also a
pioneering show as we tried to indicate
in our subtitle because of the way in
which it's exploiting the new
technologies uh neelen Now tracks the
number of hits that websites connected
to television programs get and the
website for Heroes gets far more hits
Millions more hits than the next closest
fiction program with a website the
people who are running Heroes know
something about the way about this about
how to create synergies with New Media
that will be certainly part of the
discourse we'll engage in next week and
I hope many of you will return for that
event as an added inducement I can
mention that my friend uh
and
s volcanic source of ideas Henry Jenkins
cited by some people as the newest as
the as the new Marshall mclan is going
to be the moderator next week and that
alone is probably worth the price of
admission the second thing I want to do
is remind some of you mention for some
of you who are who are newcomers to The
Forum what our basic format is the
roughly the first hour although my hope
is that the panelists because they don't
have elaborate prepared talks will
compress it even further since we're
starting 10 or 11 minutes late uh the
roughly the first hour is devoted to
conversation and discourse among the
panelists and the second hour almost
always the highlight of our sessions is
question and answer with the uh session
with the audience My Hope Is that you
will be passionate engaged even critical
and angry so long as you also remain
civil and it's been I think one of the
real signature marks of the
communications Forum something we've
always tried to encourage in our events
is the is that are these moments of
passionate interaction that we can still
regard as Civic and respectful that's my
ambition for the Forum in general and
it's especially my ambition for our
discussion today I hope especially that
there are some Skeptics in the audience
who will question some of the
assumptions that that that are being
made by by by folks on the panel and who
will ask hard questions about the
application of games to so many aspects
of experience
Eric klopper my colleague from MIT is
the director of the teacher education
program and co-director of the education
arcade at MIT he is also an associate
professor in the department of urban
studies and planning the teacher
education program at MIT uh prepares
undergraduates uh prepares MIT
undergraduates to become Math and
Science
teachers Eric's research focuses on the
development and use of computer games
and simulations for building an
understanding of Science and complex
systems Eric will be the moderator and
and
uh empresario for everything that
follows Eric thank
you um so uh first of all I'd like to
extend our the thanks to the
communications forum and of course the
center for future Civic media and their
support from the KN Foundation um a a
large contingent of which are here
visiting us today so I'd like to thank
them for their support um I'd also I
guess like to give a call out to um a
group a contingent from Pepperdine who's
visiting us today um and as president at
The Forum and uh I feel like I'm a bit
of a talk show host is there anybody
from New York
here excellent yay anybody from
California um I'm G I'm going to uh we
decided that we we talked about a week
or so ago about what the format we
should use for today's uh discussion
should be and uh we thought we'd Buck
the trend a little bit of of uh of any
kind of formalized talks and prepare
today mostly as a as a conversation um
and we discussed some topics of
conversation um that we would that we
would have um I'm a little concerned
because these guys are both pretty shy
um so there's going to be probably some
long awkward pauses where they decide
they don't want to say anything but I'll
try to kind of fill in the interstitial
spaces
there um but I I did say I would give
them at least a few minutes to introduce
themselves and talk about some of their
interests and some of their background
and some of uh how they got to the place
that they are um so that will be the
that will be the extent of our formal
presentation then we'll kind of do a
little bit of Q&A and we'll do that
roughly for the first hour I have um
some conversations that I prepared um to
talk about with these nice gentlemen and
then we will open it up to the to the
audience in general to uh to have
further questions so that's the format
um I will let Mario um introduce himself
and and talk a little bit about how he
got here okay great I want to sayk uh
first and foremost uh thanks for all of
you for uh inviting me and having me
here it's really a pleasure and uh an
honor to be here and I'm humbled to
share some of my experiences with you
this evening um as you can start up on
the screen here I I'm just going to walk
you through uh a little brief background
of who I am uh because I do think that
in some senses uh I have a different
context or a different perception of
some of what's Happening as it relates
to video games and education um so I'll
walk you through and then hopefully
you'll get a little bit of the story of
the life and how I ended up here so
number one I started out as a little kid
with an interest in taking apart
computer games my first one I took apart
was the Atari 2600 it was a nice thing
to do but my drove my parents crazy who
were on limited funds and would see
their their their hard-earned money
spread out on the living room floor the
day after it was purchased so you can
only imagine the cringing that they were
doing as parents but they supported my
curiosity which was which was very
important um from that uh I somehow
ended up with a name Mario uh which I
found out had no relation to Super Mario
it was more that my father seemed to be
into Godfather movies or something and
that's where the Mario came from but
nonetheless uh Super Mario Brothers
haunted me during high school as
everyone would tease me and ask me where
is Luigi uh so that was a a pretty big
problem I then grew up and found myself
in the corporate world and as you can
see I used to push a lot of paper in
sales Arena around technology I decided
let me get a checklist going this
doesn't seem like the right path decided
to do technology and computers and held
several positions from Network
Administration to web development to
user support um all various uh uh
different positions uh throughout
technology and it's been this kind of
ride on this technology learning curve
ever since um from there I ended up in a
unique position after working in the
Private Industry uh the mayor of
Baltimore City said hey we're doing this
thing uh we hear uh we're doing this
thing called the digital Harbor this is
out of Baltimore mayor Martin Ali and uh
the red tape obviously you understand
what that means so I found myself
leaving Private Industry to go head into
uh red tape and the whole idea was to
create a position that wasn't there
before that was about bringing
Technology Solutions to the city in
other words how could we create Economic
Development programs socioeconomic uh
development programs that could not only
enable our citizens to be more digitally
Savvy and be able to apply for job
uh but also how could we Bridge
relationships between some of our higher
learning institutions like John's
Hopkins and spin out some of their
Research into the market and how could
we find connectivity points to uh create
that vibe in Baltimore City and hone
that vibe in Baltimore City so after
being there for uh several years he
decided to go on and become the governor
I said uh I'll do my own thing now it
was fun uh but he uh one of the things
that we did announce that was one of
several projects that we did that I
still to this day reflect upon is when
we took the City Wireless and if you go
back a few years you know 2001 this was
a big deal to talk about a city thinking
about moving its uh citizens Wireless
and what does that mean and how can that
impact education how did that enable
tourism how did that enable uh Business
Development uh so that was a very big uh
deal for us in one of the uh proud uh
portions of that tenure all along I
enjoy talking I just love to talk
so while I had all these jobs in the
technology field I ended up always
seeming to find my way into being either
the corporate spokes person about
technology the person that was seen as
someone that could communicate in
layman's terms and break down some of
the things that were happening in these
complex worlds that we live in so I
decided at some point to try my own
radio show and there's a whole other
story behind that but I'll save that for
another day but uh in 1999 I had about
maybe 20 or so households it was a very
low wied station bought my own airtime
and I joke that nobody listened because
it was just such a small uh small Arena
uh so you flast fast forward a little
bit uh to uh 2007 and I'm actually
interviewing people like Sid Meyer so if
anyone knows who Sid Meyer is right but
uh one of the uh best creators of of
this time I guess you could say if you
played the game civilization and other
games of that that's uh who Sid Meyer is
so nonethe nonetheless you know we go
from what 20 households to uh 17 million
or so households with a combination of
different programs like Morning Edition
like uh news and notes with fari DEA
like uh my XM uh Daily Talk Show and
then some of the um television programs
that I do for Comcast and other outlets
so it's been a great ride communicating
technology um that's kind of been my
thing and then as it relates to gaming
I've always had an interest in gaming
obviously dating back to when I was a
kid I co-founded a program called the
urban video game Academy so myself
Joseph Salter as well as rodick Woodruff
so the three of us got together and said
hey there is a problem in the industry
there aren't enough uh women creating
games designing games and there
certainly are not enough minorities uh
developing uh games in the industry what
is the problem well it's exposure it's
education it's Role Models it's the fact
that they don't know that these are even
career tracks the parents don't know
that there are degree programs so how do
we put that into a model make it free to
Inner City students that want to come
and make an after school or summer
school uh program so we ran this pilot
for about 3 years uh a lot of press USA
Today CNN and others as well as NPR
picked up the story and uh supported
what we were trying to do with the
initiative and it's really this is
really something that's it it's not I
want to pause just on this one part I am
trying to be fast for the sake of time
but I do want to pause and take a breath
for a second on this one part because I
think while we talk today about how
games can impact education and where
that impact uh is working where it may
not be working what are the challenges
uh one of the things that we are working
on or I'm working on now is really tying
the development cycle of video games the
the cycle of creating a game of creating
a character of creating a narrative
story to core academics so instead of
just teaching kids how to develop gains
we're more teaching them we're hooking
them by something they love to do and
that is to learn and play games but what
we're trying to do is tie that into
Middle School curriculum so that when we
are on a screen that has an X and Y AIS
or we're on a screen where a wireframe
is there before it's a character we can
reinforce geometry and Mathematics and
physics oh you want to write uh the
objectives and the narrative story oh
that's creative storytelling do you know
your sentence structures do you so we're
trying to tie in the development process
through core academics and that's where
our challenge is right now and so we're
in the process of of putting those
pieces together and in 2008 um um we we
have uh spun off the partners are all
doing their own things now and so we're
I'm taking those Lessons Learned and
creating a launch of a new Academy in
2008 and um invite all of those that are
interested to understand more about this
it's really an exciting process that
we're going through so that pretty much
gives you uh background of me outside of
radio TV and online media I do we do
have a company I actually run a company
called Mario Armstrong media and we
consult and we've consulted everyone
from charter schools in Baltimore City
all the way over to corporate clients
like a and a variety of different
initiatives as well as doing uh public
speaking and events around STEM Science
technology engineering and math we do
events to really try to spark the
interest in our youth to want to go down
the Innovative path in a unique and
different different way so I hope uh
that gives you a quick synopsis of of of
who I am and what I do and and if could
I take one other quick minute did I do
pretty good did I do fast all right
because I I just uh I just want to you
know when when you're have an
opportunity to speak at MIT right this
is like the the intellectual capital of
the world as far as as far as I'm
concerned right if you call it that you
can have two
minutes it's the intellectual capital of
the world so as I travel around and do a
lot of public speaking to to different
audiences and age groups and and so on
and so forth you know like our company
has sat around the table and we started
thinking about products that we thought
would be neat to bring to Market ourself
so I just want to take this as a market
research opportunity real fast like 30
seconds to just get your read on whether
I'm on to something or if I'm way out in
left field here so we see a lot of kids
using the internet and and many of you
would say oh well they're playing video
games at home and uh you know there the
outdoor exposure is becoming less and
less so we started thinking about well
how do we bring sun and excitement back
to these kids so we came up with an idea
called the USB uh PC Tanning
Center and and and you know maybe by the
time we launch it it'll be the firewire
PC Tanning Center but right now it's the
USB one and and this is a snapshot of
what it looks like so so as you can see
it has two base units here that feature
some ultraviolet rays here and and we
even include we we include these uh
little eyeglass things with the package
they the ball cover thingies they they
come with this package we haven't quite
figured out the okay I'm just joking
take it from the laugh that maybe it's
not that bad of an idea as a prank prank
item maybe all right well thanks so much
for your time and I appreciate being
here and look forward to our discussion
uh as it relates to this topic thanks
again
[Applause]
thanks over to you Ian okay maybe I can
get up on the screen
here oh yeah yeah those are the small
the smaller versions of me um okay let's
see here um my name's Ian bogus I teach
at Georgia Tech and I run a studio a
game studio called persuasive games I'm
uh I'm a video game critic and designer
which is a good job to have um I wanted
to tell you um just in a few minutes
about what I do um and I thought I would
do that first um um by showing you an
example of some of the things um that
that trouble meat um so this is um one
of the topics that we might be thinking
about uh lately uh oil we could picked
anything else but um when I think about
the world and um the complexity of it um
it strikes me that uh that that's a
subject we don't uh treat um in as much
detail as we could so think about oil
for a minute and just imagine the ways
that we might engage it um in our
thinking and our daily practice I mean
you know certain certainly there's
topics like geochemistry and seismology
and we might want to know where we could
go Drilling and you know what kind of
places in the world those mean but maybe
in order to do that we we we should
understand something about the uh the
history of of conflict in those regions
especially like in the Middle East and
Africa where um where there's a
considerable amounts of oil those happen
to be you know largely parts of the the
developing world or maybe we think about
the the Futures markets on which uh uh
uh petroleum trades and the relationship
between that and global capitalism or
between global capitalism and let's say
ecology which also seems to have
something to do with oil um you know
Logistics and commerce and um and and
things like uh the way that we live also
seem to be related in fact the only
reason that we need to drive so much is
because of the kind of ways that we
dwell especially in in this country um
and that brings up questions in my mind
like uh issues of Labor why why do we
work in the way that we do and how are
our cities planned around that and how
might we be in fact healthier if we um
if we walked or if we uh built Community
Gardens that didn't rely on transporting
our food over many thousands of miles um
with petroleum uh uh fueled fleets and
uh and so forth and you know I live in
Atlanta where uh where Transit is is is
less of an option but in fact is deeply
related to issues of race and the
development of our Metropolitan system
in the 1960s and 70s was uh deeply tied
to uh to race relations or or the lack
of them and you know so these are
political issues really and and I think
that you know when we start to kind of
think about any kind of Topic in the
world um this is what it ends up looking
like is this complex web of
interconnected issues but but yet if I
look at the ways that we have chosen to
translate um media and our engagement
with the world through media um it
doesn't strike me that we're taking
advantage of that challenge um so you
know when we use um mobile devices um to
send 160 character messages or uh or
when we write um 20w posts on our blogs
or um or or a little insif ific
whatevers on Twitter or two-minute
videos that we put on YouTube um is that
the best way of getting at the the
complexity that I see in in the world um
whereas video games which which are a
topic of of of study um that uh that I
think are related uh to these other
media um video games of all kinds in
fact uh seem to be very good at
addressing complexity and complexity of
many issues uh and they do this in my
mind um by building models um rather
than taking the ways that we communicate
the way that we we've always
communicated with with words or with
letters or with images and simply
putting those uh on computers so that we
can translate them uh transmit them on
the Internet um video games allow us to
build models um these are a new kind of
representation of these things uh and
those models make claims about how
things work um or how they might work
differently uh and they allow us to have
experiences that are constrained by them
computational representation when we
build models with computer code are
tremendously flexible and they make it
possible for us to model almost anything
um theoretically this is a a question
I've tried to address in my research um
this is a recent book on that topic but
it's also something I've tried to
address in in my game design work um the
kinds of experiences that we can have uh
constrained uh by the models that that
we might build around them and and I
think this goes for a wide variety of
subjects like um why I might or might
not want to buy a three uh a three row
seat SUV or um what it's like to work uh
and manage a ice cream store or um you
know the possible these are all games uh
that we've made in my studio um or the
the the pros and cons of using um wind
energy in a community um or the Absurd
arbitrary nature of Transportation
Security
um or um or what a what a a public
policy issue like uh the recent debate
on uh on U on visas in Immigration would
might feel like or the relationship
between uh the petroleum industry and um
and
uh um natural disaster and so forth or
or um uh the politics of nutrition um
and you know we make we're used to
making characters in games um maybe this
is a different kind of character than
we're used to making in a game um that
we might you know put inside of a world
and imagine uh what it might be like to
live in that world and make choices
about what we eat and what we do but to
have to be able to afford those choices
and in fact be able to uh to change the
uh uh the nature of the of the policies
under which we live um through subsidy
or through regulation or through being
able to afford health care or not and so
forth so these are some examples of um
of games and and what I think the
potential is for games to address uh
complexity uh and that's uh that's the
the area of intersection that I see
between uh uh uh video games and and
Civic
engagement
thanks
so I I'll kind of start out with some um
some broad questions and uh try to take
us down some some Pathways but I imagine
that we may um we may diverge from that
as the conversation flows um uh Mar you
mentioned the the term uh using video
games or studying video games and making
video games to quote impact
education um your terms Ian were things
about um understanding complexity of
issues and you kind of when you did the
o picture there there are a lot of
different things from history to
politics to to science that you put in
there um and so if we think about the
use of games Beyond entertainment that
doesn't necessarily mean um that they're
not entertaining because I think that
games probably by definition we won't
get into the definitions today but
probably by definition are
entertaining um but but what what is Ed
what is impacting education what is
understanding these complexities um I I
tossed around some words here do we use
game to quote inform is it kind of like
understanding some issue at some broad
level is it to Enlighten to kind of
raise awareness of an issue or is it
really to kind of educate and kind of
deliver a particular message um as as an
example of of the of the kind of Latter
um kind of an extreme example
particularly with um what might be
considered Civic engagement we we had
spoken with a group some time ago who
had very particular messages that they
wanted to deliver through games they
wanted people to be good to their
neighbor and other kind of messages like
that and their kind of model was somewh
um antithetical from ours perhaps but it
was like well you know if you do the
wrong thing you should be corrected and
kind of pushed back on the right path
but there's a lot of people that kind of
look at that the way that you should
kind of use games so how do you how do
you see learning or educating or
informing through games is what's what's
the right word that we can kind of be
most powerful with this
medium um well first of all I I don't
think the games have to be fun
um so so let's get that definition out
of the
way um and in fact uh just as a lead
into an answer to your question um maybe
the the way to think about it is not to
think about a way that games might be
educational or might engage people or
what have you but to admit that there
are probably many possible ways that
this could take place and then in fact
if we've been looking at this medium and
imagining that it's this monolith that
there's there's video games and they're
all the same essentially right I mean
you know one one video game is the same
as the next
um and you just choose them based on
personal preference and use them to
distract yourself instead of doing your
homework or instead of going outside um
but we could we could say that of books
I suppose too uh if we if we really
wanted to and uh I don't think any of us
would agree that that's the case so I
think there's there's something like
this spectrum of of of possible uses um
and experiences that we could have with
video games the problem is that the um
the medium especially the let's say the
last 10 or 15 years of of the commercial
medium um haven't given us a a great uh
uh perspective on that possibility space
but only only some very narrow portion
of it so now we're looking for new
domains and new terrain and we're trying
to kind of find those open spaces and
then when we find one we think oh gosh
like maybe I can do something here
because I'm going to borrow these you
know conventions from this game and make
and instead of you know wandering around
and um and doing favors for other people
now you have to have a you know a
nutritional plan or something um and
we're slowly kind of you know uh tapping
and and and and and opening up those
spaces um uh but in in in large part
there's a tremendous amount of work to
do um so I I'm I'm suspicious that
there's a single uh a single approach or
a single method um uh for learning in
games or what have you um even in one
particular context we might find we
might find many of them yeah if I had to
U I would I would support um some of the
points that Ian is saying but I would
maybe maybe not necessarily differ I
guess my answer because I do agreee with
him that we should be looking at the
possibilities but my answer when I think
of that question is they do all of those
they they do inform they do Enlighten
and they they do educate um they may do
it in a different way and your intended
message may not be always what the
received message ends up being um but I
and I to go back to your other point as
well about should games be developed
with an agenda or or with a mission in
mind and I think of other games that
like food force uh was clearly developed
with an agenda in mind of understanding
uh nutrition and poverty and so I mean
I'm sure there are other games that and
there's one right I just said one game
out of you know the Infinity of of games
that we could uh recommend or talk about
or suggest up here on the panel I guess
my point when it comes to this question
of can they be used um Beyond
entertainment uh I understand that
question because largely of the type of
people that I'm dealing with are
politicians are uh educators are uh
nonprofit uh executive directors and and
no offense to any of those uh folks
maybe a little
offense glad he said it um but but the
the literacy level of how games can be
used is not understood by all and what
we have to do sometimes we're so close
to the industry that we forget that and
we we we get bogged down in this oh this
is a great game and and this is the
mission and we lead with this what we
want this mission to be first instead of
thinking about the game more openly and
so um my challenge is educating people
that there are reasons to play games
Beyond entertainment and I think that is
a realistic challenge that people should
start having a smarter uh more um
engaging and transparent dialogue about
as long as we continue to have
politicians across the country who say
no you know across this nation that um
say no to PlayStation uh and and they
really just don't get it uh or they read
their their their staffer notes take it
from someone that's been inside of of of
government they read points off of their
staffers notes uh until we start having
more meaningful dialogue um I think that
entertainment question will continue to
be asked because what is covered in the
media what is covered in the media is
Sound by culture what is covered in the
media is neg negativ negativity rules if
it bleeds it leads right I mean this is
the stuff that they say in newsrooms and
so they don't want to talk about um a
force more powerful you know a video
game about nonviolent struggle they want
to talk about Grand Theft Auto and how
that's ruining our kids and so I I I
think um my point is absolutely there is
education uh Beyond just the
entertainment realm and the minute we
could start having more discussions
about serious games or whatever the
standardization is on the on the
classification of that category which I
also think is part of an issue is it an
Interactive Learning Experience is it a
serious game what is it um that other
side of the culture that's developing
games for other reasons Beyond
entertainment is real and needs to have
much more uh communication to Everyday
folks that are making decisions uh about
whether or not these games show up in
our our educational school systems or
about whether or not these games uh have
any meaningful uh uh U value when your
kid is playing 40 hours of a video game
in the household so absolutely my you
know I'm sorry to sound maybe kind of
Full Circle but um I just wanted to
point out some examples that I do think
that the question is valid and that it
can do all of those and more Beyond
entertainment did you I mean I mean
there's there's a lot we could say there
there are kind of two ways of looking at
the intersection of of video games and
politics one is um the question uh uh
what in what way can can video games
about political issues um inform people
or engage them with those issues another
is to look at the the way that um that
politicians use video games um
rhetorically without any concern for the
content of any individual game and it's
just very convenient I I mean you know
it's a it's it's such a low hanging
fruit really uh uh for um uh someone
seeking elected office uh to uh to point
to video games as as a as a kind of
values issue especially let's say you're
you're trying to establish yourself as
some kind of a Centrist uh uh you know
who who's interested in family values
and and I'm not going to name names uh
you know we know who they are uh it's
very convenient um and there's very
little to be lost really uh at least it
would seem that way because the the the
you know g games are for kids right kids
don't vote uh you know this these would
be the kind of kind of line of thinking
um so if we imagine that there are those
two those two camps um one of the things
that surprised me so much about uh uh
both the the kind of game uh the game
research community and the industry
itself is how much uh we are willing to
go ahead and accept the frame of the
politicians rather than to make our own
and to spend a bunch of time trying to
defend games and create these whole
organizations around uh you know trying
to uh uh uh Lobby for for for game
advocacy and for game players as a kind
of demographic group that deserves
protection and I just I just think that
kind of line of thought is totally
wrong-headed
um uh not in its Spirit but in its
strategy and we should we should we
should just go after a different frame
uh for the media and and as part of that
make new examples of it um or or point
out the the existing examples that that
do something different uh that's much
harder to argue
with so so you mentioned there that um
games are for
kids um and so for thinking about an
audience who were who were kind of
targeting um with games for civic
engagement I mean it seems kids is the
kids are and we can think of kids as
well I'm as I get older I kids get get
older it seems
so maybe I'll call kidss anything up to
25 at this
point um so is that is is that and
should that be the target audience and
and if if it's not if it's only one
among many how do we break out of that
given that there's that is the or is
that the Prime video game audience right
uh
no the short short answer next question
short answer short answer is no um I
mean the longer answer requires a bit of
explanation I think um because we we we
do have a lack of media literacy um as
you pointed out around the medium and
also a very short memory it turns a very
short cultural memory about it um the
the video game as a as a for the
computer game um when it when it first
appeared in in I mean commercially in
the early 70s was was solely for adults
these were games you played in in
taverns uh and they they shared much
more in common with with pinball and
with darts and with that sort of
activity
uh than they did with anything else uh
and uh some of those were translated for
for the home uh by the mid '70s um with
the idea of of kind of bringing them
home bringing pong home and that was
where the Atari um that was the whole
idea behind the Atari uh was was taking
some of these popular arcade games and
making it possible to experience them uh
in the home I'm I'm hopeful that we can
just turn the rest of our conversation
really into a conversation about the
Atari uh actually I knew that was res um
you won't believe what I found in there
and uh
actually I know exactly what you found
it I'm sure you've taken a few apart and
the um the um the the the arcade culture
of the early ' 80s which had the same
kind of you know we had the same
negative reactions too oh it's uh uh you
know destroying youth um in fact one of
the first examples of of video game
controversy um and now I'm just
completely digressing is uh uh in 1976
uh there was an arcade uh well coin up
game um Called Death Race uh that was uh
kind of loosely based on Death Race 2000
which was a a film of sorts
um and uh and you would it was very
crude um in its in its visual appearance
and you had this sort of car that you
could drive over these uh I think they
were described as as goblins or ghouls
or zombies or something um but you drove
cars it it was the first game in which
you could drive cars over people um and
it was it was tremendously controversial
and it was eventually pulled and there's
a lot we could say about it so so in
that way that that kind of transition
started to happen even in even in the
mid-70s um but there's a long kind of
complicated relationship between the the
the games industry and and the toy
industry and whether they are or aren't
toys and uh sold at the toy fair but
also at the at the Consumer Electronics
Show um but it's not until the mid 80s
it's it's really Nintendo's fault that
we think that games are for kids because
when when it is it when they um
resuscitated the market in the mid 80s
with the with the the Nintendo
Entertainment System they did so by kind
of back backdooring into the toy Market
with this robot and then imposing a um a
licensing scheme that required uh
published titles to be essentially
vetted and approved uh by them and
there's there's a tremendous Untold
History of censorship in the in the um
uh in these games Nintendo Ser decided
oh well no you can't have that in the
game because it's not appropriate for
our audience um so you know this
happened over time um but I think what
it shows is you know actually if we if
we if we just think back 30 years we we
see a medium that was enti for adults
and now we we have no memory of that
whatsoever um so it's my inclination
that we can we can simply forget um we
can we can dismiss this claim that that
video games are are for kids and instead
ask um what kinds of video games might
be useful for different kinds of people
in different
contexts and I think we'll pick up that
thread in a second but I'll I'll throw
it over to Mario you you have anything
to add on the who's our audience um yeah
I think um I I I think I think the
approach to that shouldn't be limited by
an answer um be because the audience is
that widespread uh and if you are to
look at any of the uh if you follow
industry statistics and and believe
those sources um you know they would
tell you that the average video game uh
the average age of a gamer is what 3 33
33 years old I believe is uh this the
statistic um so that gives you an idea
of maybe who the what the average age of
a gamer is but when you ask me um who
should be playing games my answer is not
the kids because they're already doing
it my answer is Teachers should be
playing games that's that's what I think
I think of I think um um Civic activists
should be playing video games I think uh
church leaders should be playing video
games I think uh people that run
nonprofits that uh disseminate money
around education and poverty and
technology strategies should be playing
video games whether it's someone on your
staff that you trust that's younger than
you or you just don't have time to do it
so be it but I think the discussion and
gaming shouldn't be seen as just a
recreational activity it should be seen
as a time of reflection and study uh and
research and understanding and there are
enough forums there are enough people
doing great things um to to have enough
of a start to have people that don't
traditionally play games so I think
that's the to me that's the audience I
try to focus on um I I watch the kids
because I love to watch how they play
games and that gives us fuel to
understand how does that um start to
influence uh Civic media how does that
influence um their citizenship how does
that influence their moral values and
and so it's great to to see whether
they're on a handheld game that's
connected through the internet with
playing with people from other cultures
uh or they're playing on a cell phone um
or a laptop or or a console it's really
invigorating to watch that but I think
so many other people aren't seeing the
same energy the same creativity from
quite frankly kids that we write off
kids that we are willing to just write
off I'm not you know many of the many
kids play games that have access to them
um but you'll be surprised at how many
kids you may not think have access to a
$400 gaming console and and that trumps
everything else in the household um
Believe It or Not uh and and you know
it's um when you go through some of the
different areas of of the country and
seeing how different kids are
interacting with games it's very
interesting I I mean it's it's so I
think to answer your question then we
can get into some of those other areas
but uh to answer your question I think
teachers uh really should start playing
them in nonprofit leaders and and if we
can get a if if someone could help us
maybe Ian and and maybe we can get MIT
to start this but if we can get like a
uh a a congressional land party that
would be like that that would go a long
way like if you could you know if we
could just get Congress to stay up late
one night and just and maybe we just
take it to Capitol Hill and we just do a
land party there but and and I'm joking
right but staffers but that's but see
that might not be such a bad thing you
know staffers is that what you I I said
they would send their staffers to the
yeah and and you know but but you know
some of those staffers are influential
staffers so yeah maybe the congresswoman
or Congressman can't get over there but
maybe they could send their staff or it
was if it was made appealing enough and
the message was sent clear enough so
that we could start that education
process but those people that think are
the ones that need to play games that's
who I'm talking about yeah I mean the I
just want to follow up because the the
idea of um of teachers and and parents
and people in in positions of of
so-called authority to uh to to become
game players is is really important and
it's not hard to to convince yourself of
this I think because we uh we you know
when think about being a parent um you
know you you U might might read to or
with or with your kids or you might be
concerned about the things that they're
reading or or or or watching um at the
cinema or on television and the reason
that we can make those judgments that we
uh that we can make decisions like oh no
I don't I don't think this movie is
right for my class or or for my child is
because uh we have tremendous deep
literacy in those media and we've
watched them uh and we've seen a a vast
uh kind of array of different kinds of
films a read a number of different kinds
of books and understand the conventions
uh how they work what it means to go and
see something what a director's work is
like compared with someone else's and so
forth uh so the only way to develop that
with games is to is to play them and
there's there's other benefits that we
get that we just don't we just don't
have and it's it's the idea of being
there on the couch um uh or or next to
next to the the computer uh with a with
a with anyone with a child or or an
older an older kid who um who is having
an experience that needs to be worked
through in some way so I mean if I've
got a story if you can indulge me that's
related to this um let's see here
stories are great okay I I went through
this very quickly earlier you guys know
this
game this is Animal Crossing um this is
the best
game and story that's
it we can you can all go know um uh this
is an amazing an amazing game it's it's
a game for the for it's a commercial
game for the Nintendo uh last last
generation Nintendo uh console Home
console uh and uh you run away from home
and you go live in Animal Crossing uh so
it's already perfect for your
kids um but the there's a lot of amazing
things about the game uh but the first
thing you do when you arrive in town is
um you uh you get a
mortgage uh because you don't have any
money and you don't have anywhere to
live uh and you meet Tom Nook the
raccoon real estate Tycoon of Animal
Crossing he says no problem you know so
don't worry about it um I've got some
Huts here some little Shacks you know
just pick one you can come work for me
uh and you can pay it off um and so uh
you get you get a house and then and
then you've got to pay off there's a
tremendous amount of money and you do
that by selling fish that you catch or
doing favors for other people and so
forth and eventually after you pay off
your mortgage he offers you upgr you see
the the the two-story house here uh I
mean you know why not why not expand
really uh um so uh we we've prob we've
played hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of hours of this game in my
house everybody can have their own
character inside the game in the same
world and one day when when uh my son
was five he came to me uh uh just
sometime you know random time during the
day he said dad I have a I have a
problem and I you know he was five he
was just starting to be at the point
where he he would you know kind of come
and talk to me about about such things
so I thought this is great I you know
kind of puffed up my
chest yes
[Laughter]
son um well Dad he said um
I've I can't even I don't I can't even
walk around in my house anymore I I've
because you know I I bought that that
fruit
couch and and you remember I got all
those shirts and there's that lunar rock
that you sent
me and you know so the house that you
get when you first started is very small
and you can buy things to customize your
environment right because who wouldn't
want to customize their house um I can't
I don't even have anywhere to move
around in my house but I I need more
space um so I need I need to get a
bigger house but the problem is that
this is my son you know the problem is I
spent all my money buying
stuff
I don't have any I don't have any money
left to pay my
mortgage there it
[Applause]
is so there you go
um so what' you say Dad so so we sat
down and we talked about long-term debt
you know
and and he said oh yeah that makes sense
and uh and you know he thinks credit
cards are evil now and he's sort of and
we we even talked about compounding
interest was horrified you know cuz
there's no compounding interest in
Animal Crossing at least were you able
to make an analogy and say and that's
why we have to sell your
Nintendo time to simplify yeah we we've
got um in my house we've got a throwaway
day every you know some people do spring
cleaning we do throwaway day um and it's
inspired in part by by Animal Crossing
we just try to devest ourselves of all
the objects that we that we don't have
but this is interesting right because
all of this media that that asks us to
uh custom something right oh make it
yours and Express Yourself by having a
pink phone and all that's kind of
nonsense about that where
commercialization is the way that we
that we become people um you know this
game which which appears to endorse that
is really is really much more comp
complicated uh and and my son saw right
through it in some ways uh he was five
it was it was fairly
disturbing um so yeah this is a story
about why you might want to play games
with your kids so that you can you know
or or students or whatever um so when
these experiences come up um you know
they need be worked
through great
Point um so I'll actually kind of take
that point of uh of your interaction
with your son there um in the Animal
Crossing is pretty open-ended you can
make lots of different choices and you
kind of insinuate that there's certain
things that you like to do you like to
decorate your house you like to upgrade
but different people play it in lots of
different ways um and that's kind of a
characteristic of a of a of a suite of
of a kind of game where you have lots of
different choices that you can make some
of which are some of which youve value
some of which other people might value
the game may may or may not kind of
enforce those kind of give you feedback
on those whether those were good choices
or not so in games that let you make
kind of wrong choices I mean I guess
classic one that's that CED that's
already been um that's been cited once
is Grand Theft Auto you can you can make
choices in Grand Theft Auto many of
which are bad choices and there may not
may or may not be consequences to those
in in this case here your your son kind
of made some maybe bad choices and you
were there to kind of help him guide and
point him in a positive direction and
teach him about compound interest um so
but what what is kind of the role of
games and sort of being should they be
open-ended and and allow you to make
these wrong choices should they kind of
correct you back in the right direction
um how how open-ended should they be
when you're allowed to make these uh
kind of choices and and and and perhaps
reinforce what may be conceived as
negative behaviors right um okay so
there's a there's a number of ways to
answer that question um I mean I think
there are two things there there are two
things about games that I think are very
powerful representationally one is this
model building idea that you can
construct a model of how something works
and it's always a claim about how
something works somebody's idea of how
some system works might be a social
system might be a mechanical system but
it's how something works like in this
case how uh how long-term debt works and
you can interact with that and the world
is constrained by that interaction and
the second is um uh uh taking on a role
um and that role might be um you know
the the Space Marine or that role might
be the um the taxpayer or what have you
um and so by by by not just living
someone else's life for for a brief
moment but living a life that's
constrained by a particular situation uh
we can gain insights into what it might
be like to to be in that situation and
there's I think a tremendous amount of
empathy to be gained whether or not the
situation is desirable so a game like
Grand Theft Auto actually is a pretty
interesting view into um the you know
the experience of the the sociopath or
or or the idea that there are there are
um you know there are consequences to
criminal Behavior I don't think this is
really what the game is about but it's
also it's also um it does give the the
player interesting choices to make in
those contexts um but this this is Maybe
not maybe not the best example of of a
game um uh uh for for kids for example
we wouldn't give this to our kids and
say well you know go learn about uh why
you might not want to um you know fire
on the
police you know so so they're they're
also also context uh context for them um
but but one thing I hear a lot uh that I
that I don't believe is that uh you know
what video game should do or what their
power is is letting people kind of
construct their own worlds um and then
they can they can kind of make these
environments that where they're being
creative or or something I there's
nothing wrong with that but I think it's
it's the opposite thing that interests
me the idea of living in a world you you
don't construct that isn't one that you
would choose and and understanding um
someone else's perspective uh I think
that's really
powerful yeah um when to piggyback off
of that I think one of the things that
comes to mind when you when you look at
a game you know one of the one of the
things that you're thinking about in the
design process right are are are the
outcomes the the challenges and and the
rewards and and whether or not you know
some people will say oh well you know
video games teach competition and and
but it's really interesting because if
you think back I I want to say it was um
U macropolis uh uh 84 1984 uh Will
Wright and then um that which became Sim
City uh really didn't have a winner or a
loser and it was like that was one of
the first times where you kind of
witness a game that it you won if you
won you know it was up to you as a
player to kind of win it really wasn't
up to whether or not you scored or
racked up all these points or made all
of this money and that was a whole that
was a mind shift at that point of what
the end product of a game can be and how
I can engage in a game wait I can play a
game and it not have to end this way I
don't I I don't have to just be a loser
or a winner um I don't know if some of
you had a chance to play um Fable uh
when it was out on on the Xbox but that
that was uh similar in that uh you know
you're in this little town and you can
make these good decisions or you can
make these bad decisions and you know as
you made bad decisions you became more
and more evil and as you became uh made
good decisions uh you become uh you
would have more and more rewards
theoretically uh the game was really
kind of simple to play but the fact that
it was giving kids an option other than
just you win or lose made you think
differently about playing the game and I
remember um I don't remember recall
exactly who wrote these books but I
remember my mom giving me books when I
was young uh that were like mystery
books that if you uh read a page and you
chose an answer at the end of that page
you would flip to a different chapter
can can anyone help me out what Choose
Your Own
Adventure let's all do that one more
time for Mario Choose Your Own Adventure
all right thank
you and I'm glad to hear that a lot of
people knew what I'm talking about but
that's that's kind of to make you kind
of reflect on something that hopefully
that you can gravitate to that if you've
been through that experience then you
now know what we're talking about when
we talk about the ability to make
choices and you know what's funny about
that I don't know about you but I've
read I read all the options I did
everything right I don't I said okay
well I'll answer it this way and go this
way and then I would read the book again
and then I would read it again and I
would Cho so what am I doing I'm
learning I'm I'm curious I'm going
through these complex uh um um worlds in
video games so um I I you know I just
think that uh uh it's we're at this
great time now where we're starting to
see more and more people that are in
developing power create games that don't
really
uh go off of the standard of you win or
lose and so when we start talking about
what are the educ what's the educational
value what can we learn uh clearly you
heard I mean that was a loss right I
mean he lost his house so I mean there's
no question that that is an L uh in the
in the L column but at the same time
it's a win uh because of the discussion
that took place between between parent
and child and so as games become more
right now we're like pushing games to
people and and as games really more ad
apt to to who we are our characteristics
our
personalities uh I think it'll start to
see more of that um uh where am I I'm
digressing a little bit but more of that
response in terms of the rewards and whe
and what those rewards may or may not be
as opposed to rewards that are dictated
by the game designer they now can be
dictated by the game player well you
know the the the the problem of um of
doing um doing things in a game that we
that are undesirable socially
undesirable um or what have you uh it's
been a real problem for me as a designer
dealing with um with Publishers and and
whatnot doing the kinds of I can imagine
the kinds of games uh that we do I was
looking for for an example um which I I
can't find uh easily but um the idea
that uh when you when you perform an
action in a game it's it's not not real
uh it's it's representational and the
decision that you're making is a
decision framed within this possibility
space of experimentation um so you might
make a choice that you know is um is not
a choice you would make
um in your own life or or you play a
role that is not one you would you would
play in your own life in order to see uh
see something from a different
perspective and and I've had this many
many times
um backfire in in designs um so uh just
one example uh there's a fear in other
words there a fear of of um of
representing things that that might seem
undesirable so we were doing this this
this uh this game at the studio recently
for a major uh that published eventually
got published on a um I guess what I'll
describe as a ma major online news media
organization you can guess what it might
be hint I live in
Atlanta um and uh it was a game about uh
uh Wildlife tra trafficking uh which is
an interesting topic uh really
interesting idea and uh interesting
problem because there's sort of these
ambig ities of not there's a lot of
moral ambiguity you know it's easy to
say well trafficking illegal animals is
wrong uh but then when you're in
situations as a trafficker where you've
got a family to feed and and um and
there other kinds of political and
social situations up for grabs then you
know the the the greyness of that
decision uh stands out um and this game
uh initially uh expressed that and then
slowly slowly slowly slowly didn't as we
moved further and further and further
into the process um and eventually when
it was released you can you can find it
um you can find it online um it was uh
essentially almost just the just as if
the uh the idea was inspiring some sort
of experience that would be on a web
page uh you know so it could be sticky
or something uh which is too bad it's
really unfortunate there's a lot of a
lot of examples of this um I mean may
maybe
I we can move on or I could I could sure
yeah I think we're we're nearing our
halfway point and I want to turn it over
to the audience shortly
um we
discussed uh briefly in in our
conversation about what would qualify as
as you you make games and you kind of
deal with kids and kind of um helping
them make games and learn what what how
do we measure our success in these cases
um you know what are whether it's
whether it's quantitative measures or
just kind of things that we get as
feedback that we know that we're kind of
we're we're successful in delivering our
message or educating our audience so I
don't know if you want to go first Mario
uh yeah I mean I I can I'm not I'm not
the AC ademic um in in that in that uh
in that traditional uh Regard in terms
of of my learning but I can say um
anecdotally with the program that we did
specifically in watching kids uh develop
games or want to play games and and once
to actually pursue learning around games
um there was immense anodal evidence
about the power of the medium uh we're
we're talking about kids that are in
underserved areas that don't have all
the means that many other folks do and
yet and still their uh desire and their
passion for learning was off the charts
when there was something relevant that
could tie into the process of why they
need to know an integer the process of
why they need to know what the X and Y
AIS is and and and and this thing called
the plane and if they want to move an
object across the screen that's called
animation that involves physics and so
um it was it was startling because we
had we we didn't go to uh areas and say
um hey kids uh you know join this
program and you're going to become a
video game developer that that wasn't
what we said I mean we just said come to
this program if you want to if you want
to and and so we ended up having some
kids that came to the program because
they wanted to but then we had a body of
kids that were forced to come and that
was the most interesting dynamic because
kids that want to be there as we all
know are totally different than the kids
that feel like this is a waste of their
time so when we started seeing the Mind
shift in students that felt initially
that this was going to be a total waste
of time especially girls especially
girls the word video game locks them up
all I for for the girls that we
experience I know that there's plenty of
women that are in the games's industry
and it doesn't lock them up but for for
these girls a lot of them they saw it as
oh that's something my brother does
uh that's something my uncle does you
know I don't play games but the minute
you start telling them you could create
your own character what would it be or
you could create your own storyline what
would it
be it's a whole different discussion and
so when you um put these kids into those
environments anecdotally my my feedback
from that experience I mean we have
surveys that we did and uh we're we're
working with the university Partners now
to try to really get the you know that
quantitative that real third party
research to come in and support some of
the antidotal things that we we've seen
but clearly kids are soaking up this
medium and they want to do more with it
they want to learn with it they want to
express themselves through it they want
to change society by using it and that's
a major major statement um so uh
anecdotally uh video games and education
and in video games uh from what we've
seen from the kids uh is it's just you
know I mean we have kids now saying Mr
Armstrong when when are you coming back
you know and so it's hard now because
what's the leave behind how how do we
follow that momentum how do we continue
to to make that kid continue to progress
on and so um I I get caught up a little
bit when I talk about those experiences
because there was a lot of Blood Sweat
and Tears to to make that program happen
off of a off of a light bulb that we
thought would work coming out of the the
video game conference at E3 and and
that's probably to me the best Testament
of this medium is on to something if it
decid Ides to have a an obligation
beyond the entertainment realm and it
would help if you know people like the
esa I'm sorry that I I didn't mean to
call out the entertainment software
Association but uh I just did if they
could uh take a moral obligation like
other media uh uh does with video games
we might see a little bit more increase
but that's my we'll save that for the
Q&A but that's my antidotal evidence of
of what I've seen in the
classroom yeah I mean um certainly
watching people um listening more than
watching um players after they've played
a game and uh trying to understand the
way that they are um framing
conversations about uh the topics that
might have been at work I mean the
example of long-term debt is one but
there's plenty of others I found in my
work one one of the stories I like to
tell is during the the dean campaign um
four years ago uh when when we did this
uh this video game um uh we which was
the first
uh the first official presidential
candidate video game right at the time
um had a lot of problems uh but one of
one of the things that came out of of of
watching people play which we could do
online they they talked about it on on
on on on the blogs and the other
websites and things um was this was a
game about Grassroots Outreach because
that was what the dean campaign was
about and uh there was this uh this
backlash of of kind of requests okay
well all this shows is that uh uh as as
a way to campaign um give me something
give me something about policy uh talk
to me about about what you're about as a
candidate um or why can't I just change
the names of the signs you know to
kinich or anyone else of my choosing
isn't it the same game really um and so
I I thought that was very interesting
and I collected um all of these uh all
of these conversations there were dozens
of them uh and sent them up to
Burlington December 2003 and said okay
here you go here's the this is the the
next stage of your campaign right here
is uh um very quickly before Iowa
talking about uh um the platform and
they said no no no we just need more
people we just need more people um so so
we make the claim at at my my studio
that we foresaw the downfall of the of
the dean campaign a month before they
did um you know and there's stuff like
that so there I think there are ways of
watching discourse um and I'm not
interested in anything um numerical here
I'm interested in in seeing the ways
that people engage with problems but but
that said I'm I'm also a pretty patient
person and I I I don't believe that
we're going to see this medium cash
itself out right
away um I think that that video games
are a type of human expression and like
other kinds of human expression um
they're going to find their place uh in
history and when we when we read uh
poetry or we watch films that have been
made either recently or or or very long
ago um they speak to us in ways that
that that the creators couldn't have
known um so I'm willing to to to wait
this out and and imagine that what I'm
doing I'm doing because it's important
to me and might be important later to
others Mar did you have one more thing
you wanted to say before I turn over the
audience no fine thanks okay so I'll um
I'll open it up to to questions from the
audience do we have a a mic person or I
guess we have mics on either side so
here we go uh I'm Rob Dy gamer uh
National R Tekken player it's just a
kind of fanatical thing I've never been
able to let go since Tekken 2 but um uh
one of the things that I was really
interested in with the you were talking
about is obviously the concept of games
not having to be fun um specifically I
don't know if you guys played Final
Fantasy Tactics PlayStation one ever
okay it's basically just chess except on
more levels and uh it's a game that no
one ever really seems to enjoy but they
still play for 120 hours per each game
because it's so much about um uh
building up you know the abilities of
your characters and being able to tackle
other challenges and things like that
it's a perfectionism thing but you can
never complete it so completionists will
play this game for hundreds of hours and
never get to the point where it's ever
really done um and then on top of that
the concept of
um as games have gotten to the point
where it's no longer the same sort of
technological adolescences like cinema
at the beginning was very gimmicky um
now games are starting to Branch out to
becoming more of an art form um and the
ways that people teach things may be
very different than you know we would
normally expect like even something like
Grand Theft Auto um which people just
are ready to harp on at all times
teaches things like resource management
and I mean the concept of passive income
was a totally foreign concept to me
until Grand Theft Auto I would never
have learned about that economic concept
in education in school with the accepted
Grand Theft Auto that just kind of
happened um but there are two specific
games I wanted to talk to you about um
they tie into the whole Fable concept of
um playing through a game for different
reasons and if you're a good character
good things happen bad things um there
was an old series about 10 years ago
came out for PC called Fallout um the
whole concept is um post nuclear
Holocaust uh RPG where you make
different decisions some of them are for
the good of people some are for the bad
of people but the storyline changes
depending on what happens with that um
and they're releasing a new version of
that for PS3 and Xbox everything the new
generation of games next year um but it
was really interesting that the first
game that I ever played like that that
introduced the concept of Karma and good
decisions changing the world around you
versus bad decisions changing world the
world around you I feel like that's more
impactful than watching it on a movie
like for example Serana was a movie
about oil and all the negative things
that happen with it but it's not as
engaging as when you're a part of it um
and there's also another game called
Army of Two which the other game I
wanted to talk about which is all about
private milit AR corporations and um the
concept that in one board you may be
trying to protect people because that's
what people are paying for but the next
highest bid in the next board you have
to assassinate the people you were just
protecting and all of the the aspects of
that where you just go for the highest
bidder it brings a lot of social
Concepts to light so the thing I'm
trying to tie together with these is how
do you imagine games as they elevate to
becoming more of an art form impacting
the next generation of Gamers um and
using that art form to try and Bridge
out and create and stir up thought
within the Gaming Community instead of
just this is the boundaries that we've
set up for you as a world to work within
and then what can you achieve within
that um yeah I mean these are great
examples of of ways that the um the
commercial industry even in the last
year has has been moving in in these
directions there's a risk though that
some of these some of these examples not
necessarily the ones that you cited um
um are are kind of kind of you know
simulations of of of real ethical or
moral dilemmas um rather than than than
engagement I've always had a problem
with the sort of karma mechanic because
I mean moral questions are not
globalized you know they're they're
personal in some way but but your
question you know is very very big
um um and and you know the there's
there's I mean any answer would be
speculative um for my part what I've
chosen to do is to uh completely ignore
and and deny the idea of the gamer okay
I just refuse to believe it there are
not Gamers there are people who might
play games sometimes um but they're not
Gamers and I think the the quicker we we
we just stop using that frame to talk
about this medium the the better off we
will
be yeah I mean um to back up again on
that point I I you know all you have to
do is look at say uh Nintendo and look
at the um explosion behind the Wii their
their latest console that really if you
look at the design of that has everyone
is it safe to say everyone here has seen
an ad or a promotion or something about
that okay so you know how it kind of
works and that it's different in its
approach to how you play a game and and
I say that to say that they think of
people as players uh not necessarily as
Gamers to to go to the one com one
comment that you make I do think it's um
you know you raised this really
interesting question about Karma and
about decisions that you can make in a
game that can impact the world uh or
impact others I mean I even think of uh
I even think of wow and some some other
games um that kind of go along those
same lines um and I do think that there
there there are things that you can
learn obviously uh within that that
process but where things down the road
uh you know as it gets more graphically
intense and and more um just intense
overall and then you have high
definition and then you have the whole a
thought process of of of you know um Web
2.0 and people want to collaborate and
do more and participate and how that may
start to evolve in games um I would
totally be speculating on where I would
see it going as well but I can say that
people want that to happen and they it
seems that way that consumers want that
to happen and want to go down that path
um so I think you raised you raised some
some really thought-provoking uh points
I don't have more of a definitive answer
for you but um something that we
continue to need to follow certainly
because those are major points that you
raised thank you we have we have long
cues on each side so I'll just ask the
speakers to who are going to ask
questions to be as succinct as you can
in your in your
questions I'm interested in a very
specific use of games with adults
working with young people and that's
where uh adults help young people
navigate um typically bureaucratic
institutions by making a comparison to
games so for example the college
application game and at times that can
sort of bend it can kind of Bend towards
a a more crft definition of game where
gaming the system is you're sort of like
hacking the system or something like
that but it can be very effective for
teaching students to be strategic inside
of those institutions the concern I have
and I wonder about your experiences
maybe Mario speaking to your experience
with young people how do you help them
be strategic inside of that using that
game analogy strategically without
stopping them from their natural impulse
to question the efficacy of those kinds
of Institutions stopping them from you
know I worry that we might be
deteriorating their ability to question
or have a reformist approach because
they're always gaming the
system
um one one thought to that would be um
you know it's interesting we didn't do
that um in our program so it's hard for
me to really you know understand that
because I mean I understand what what
you're saying and what you're asking but
we didn't do that in our program in fact
we did the we we kind of did the exact
opposite we we took kids and um had had
them reflect on part of what we did that
I think helps to answer this question is
we had them reflect on the images that
video games represent of them um and
that was uh um a different way for them
to finally actually question themselves
and question the process so we wanted
their curiosity to come out we we didn't
stifle it uh as much as I you know I
hope we didn't it didn't seem seem that
way so um I don't know if I'm the best
one to answer that question because we
didn't really have that type of
experience which is which is a good
situation to be in but maybe Ian I don't
mind speculation have you have you have
you um have you read U McKenzie work's
book G gamer Theory yeah okay you should
you should probably read it um because
he makes um he makes a a similar kind of
point you know that the uh one thing
that that that games do is show show us
how the whole world has become kind of a
a game that we where we try to maximize
resources and things like that um and uh
but I think I think you know since I
believe in representation I'm one of the
few people left who seems to um that
when we when we frame um processes as
games we when we when we abstract them
to the level of representation we also
show um or we have the potential to show
the arbitrariness of those processes or
or or the way that they're connected to
particular um historically culturally uh
contingent um scenarios that would would
then um uh lead us to moments of of
possible questioning and reform uh uh
but it is it is certainly possible just
to accept the game um and and to take it
at face value this is this is one of the
points that that Ken makes in in the
book it's uh it's which definitely worth
a read
thanks over to this
side hi um so Ian in the uh in the
example that you gave with your son and
Animal Crossing
uh obviously you know in that particular
situation it was your input that helped
your son reflect upon what was going on
he probably couldn't have looked inside
himself and learned about compound
interest or anything that um you
underestimate his kid yeah maybe I do he
is f okay
really so um when you're when you're
building a model uh obviously not
everybody has access to a mentor who can
you know help them want walk through the
model and sort of think critically about
it when you're building a model how do
you build a model that encourages that
kind of self uh that sort of
self-reflection that self-criticism it's
very easy to build a model that you
learn nothing from here's the system I
poke it it responds in these ways and I
have no idea why um how do you keep it
engaging and uh and sort of bake that
into the presentation of the model right
yeah that's a great question um the I
think that there's probably not one
strategy uh but but the the idea of um
providing feedback in in games or in
software in general has usually been a
question of of efficiency right we ask
how can we make sure that the user knows
what to do next and it's clear that this
button does this thing or what have you
in fact there's a there's a there's a
joke this is nothing to do with the
topic
that there's there's a joke um about uh
uh HCI uh the game designers about human
computer interaction I apologize if
there are any HCI researchers or
Professionals in the room um and and the
it's something like go goes something
like this you know if if if uh if if
game design was left up to HCI then all
games would have uh a button that said
press button to
win that one's yours you can you can use
that one that's it's a good one to have
in your pocket anyway um
you know so so we're we're not doing
that when we when we design these
systems that have many possible outcomes
but yet we have to leave traces of uh of
the outcomes that have occurred uh and I
think the question you asked is a is a
is really an untapped it's an untapped
design challenge because what we're
looking for is not um the maximization
of a particular kind of resource nor the
kind of free movement do whatever you
want right you can do whatever it's fine
you know but rather um a recognition
that that choices matter and when when
choices take place um we have to give we
have to provide feedback for what's
happened so when we were working on this
fat World game which is the the politics
of nutrition game which is based I mean
significantly stolen Concepts from
Animal Crossing there you know we got
this world and we we asked this exact
question um and uh we decided that we
would um that we would build the um the
feedback into the social model that we
wanted to represent so for example let's
say that you want to know how what your
health is like because how else can you
know if the decisions you're making you
know the the nutritional decisions
you're making constrained by your income
based on your social class are cashing
out um and but the problem is that if
you can't afford to get the health care
then you can never know anyway um and so
so that's a model that's in there um
although if you're if you're wealthy
then then you can actually you can go
and just do whatever you want because
the way that you vote in fat world is
with money basically um so so it's a
perspective that you could see from
multiple places and then we've tried to
we've tried to build a model so that um
that users will have a reason to go and
look at it from multiple different
perspectives I don't know if it's going
to work or not but but what we we've had
a go at it at
least Henry okay I wanted to pull us
more deeply into the space of Civic
engagement we've talked a lot here about
games less about Civic engagement so two
questions that I think are
interconnected one sort of plays to
Ian's card the other to Mario's on Ian's
side there hasn't been a lot of
follow-ups on the Howard Dean game in
the election we've seen more creative
uses of Myspace and social networks more
creative by YouTube by the candidate so
it invites us to think about what are
the affordances of games uh for various
kinds of political processes how do we
read games against other kinds of Civic
media and other ways of communicating
ideas to the public on Mario's side as I
see it the urban games Academy was
pushing in part to diversify the games
industry so what perspectives are we not
hearing because the games that are
currently exists reflect the viewpoints
of particular segments of the population
so how does it m why does it matter who
has access the ability to create games
that might engage us with the political
process or what are the consequences of
a world where some people have the
ability to express their ideas through
games and others don't so I just throw
those open as a ways of getting us to
think about the Civic engagement part of
our topic a bit
more yeah um go ahead um as it as it uh
relates to um I mean some of the
startling statistics if you don't know
um survey was done by uh the
international game developers associ
assciation about diversity uh in the
industry and what you see is that there
is less than 10% female there is about
2.1% African-American and
2.3% uh Hispanic um and uh I'm running a
blank on some of the other uh stats
right now but that gives that kind of
gives you an understanding of the
picture um and we're talking about what
an 11 billion or more industry so when
we talk about uh how that impacts the
discussion or how that impacts the
development of games I mean one can
point to and I don't like to always use
this example but it is probably one of
the best if not the best uh but it
wasn't designed this way with with this
question to answer and that is uh when
you look at the team that developed the
Sims and you look at the game The Sims
and how popular it is but if you look at
the um creativity Behind The Sims the
demographics of that creativity you'll
see a very diverse team um more diverse
than what you may see in in many other
places and and you start to wonder why
well why is that you know the number one
selling game or why is it so successful
is it just because it was a great game
or was there really something there in
the diversity of the perceptions the
diversity of experiences and the
diversity of the backgrounds that made
that game really successful and when you
start to look at that in terms of a um
political discussion or a Civic
engagement um first off you know kids
need to feel that they have a voice um
and I think games allows them to feel
that they do have a voice and when we
put kids in the urban video game Academy
and said create your own game you we
came up they would come up with you know
they didn't come up with games that you
would expect you you may some of our
preconceived noses were oh it'll be
about music or it'll be about um I don't
know uh commercialization buying clothes
or or fashion or latest gear and yeah
there was there were some of those but
more and more what we saw were games
that were about how to um how to um not
be how to impact poverty we saw games
that were developed about how to clean
up the trash in my neighborhood um we
saw games that were developed about
whether or not do we make a decision to
buy food or pay the electric bill so I
mean these were very these they
internalized their experiences their
thoughts their backgrounds and wanted to
put that into a simulation of some sort
and be able to try to master this
complex world so if you think about that
and you start to uh talk about politics
and and and Civic engagement in general
you can see clearly that kids want to
talk about issues that are affecting
them and they may or may not just have
the wherewithal to have those
discussions but games creates a platform
that they can relate to that they can
have this discussion in a surprising way
I mean when you sit down with them and
discuss the narrative and the story well
what do you mean by this what are the
challenges what would be the outcomes
what would be the rewards you really
start to see a different student it's
amazing so I think um to to answer your
question I I think it's a powerful way
of shaping at least uh their exposure to
making an impact to society and and in
all the different ways they could make
that impact to society through
games are you ready yeah I I was just I
was queuing up some uh visual kind of
just Dro visual aids short uh for my
response um so um I I remember in 2004
um in an interview of some kind um
making the prediction that in the 2008
election every major candidate would
have their own PlayStation 3 game
that was
wrong um and I think one of the reasons
why I mean part part of it is that uh
we've gotten we' we've become distracted
and I'll use that word distracted by um
by other Trends in in computer
technology including um um social media
and uh an online video and so forth um
but uh I also suspect that part of the
problem is the attempt to go to the
source the attempt to do this in an
official way um so this is a complex
topic but in some ways the idea of
dealing with politics with the
politicians in the way that I think
games have the power to deal with
politics which is exactly to show what
the public policy problems are at work
rather than the campaign problems that
are covering up the public policy
problems um how do we do that while we
are still um engaged directly with with
the organizations or the camp or the
campaigns um if I can get my um my
screen up here I've also so um you so so
as a response to that one of the things
I started to do was look at the news
media as a one one outlet for this we we
started working on this idea of of news
games these sort of small um games
they're they're like uh it's just black
right now so that's by Design um um
these small games that uh that uh deal
with with with with current events and
um and and that too has posed problems
you know so the objects that appear in
the of the objects that appear in the in
the airport security game um this is
just a random slide I picked the thing
that the Arrow's pointing to by the way
is is is pressurized cheese and and you
may not know this but if you go to the
tsa's website and look for a list of
prohibited items pressurized cheese is
on the
[Laughter]
list the the object below it in is is
hummus by the
way you know is it a gel
um it's from the Middle East I don't
know I don't know
anyway so you know this is a published
game and and millions of people have
played it but this is an object that did
not appear in the game that was
originally designed to um and there are
a lot of reasons for this um and this is
a game that was never published on the
New York Times
um so there are
um there are challenges um there are
challenges dealing with uh with the
structures the the the the structures of
of of of the news media and the
structures of um of uh of the political
media that I suspect we have to go
around to some extent there's G there's
kind of a I guess my answer Henry is we
got to go punk
rock we we have to just do this and not
ask for permission anymore and not ask
for endorsement anymore which means
finding ways uh to make that happen uh
uh financially having the time all those
sorts of
things great
point I'm here from the Museum of
Science and one of the things that I do
is introduce people to new science and
technology and what we've been doing
lately is showing people second life and
other you know online worlds and I've
had the experience of just a couple days
ago I had maybe a 75-year-old guy who'd
never played video games before saw a
second life on the big screen and said
how do I get this I want this I've had
little kids say I can make money in this
game and there are games you mentioned
the Sims people know about brain age and
the Wii and other such things that they
really get visceral reactions from
people people who don't play games want
these things and you've been talking
about some of the kind of components of
those things I'm curious about what you
think some of the other ones are but the
I think that the real basic question I
have is if you had your Congressional
land party what would you
play that's a great question uh a
first-person
shooter I'm just joking I'm just joking
I'm going to see it we're going to see
it tomorrow frag your
Congressman it would go over so well I'm
just joking I'm just joking
um I I would probably um you
know part of me wants to go punk rock
part of me wants to go with all right we
have to play something that they'll
understand and so part of me says if we
have the staffers we'd go punk rock and
we play some
really neat and cool and and engaging we
might play something like uh we might
play something like um a force more
powerful which might by the way we might
play with uh someone a congressman as
well uh it's a a game about Noni
non-violent strategy how do you it's a
simulation um and it walks you through
about 10 different scenarios and you are
a chief strategist and you have to learn
all these variables and understand uh
things that come out of city council
things that may come out of a uh uh a
dictator um and how you would navigate
this uh simulated Society to get your
cause heard and and dealt with in a
nonviolent way um but you know I i'
would also want them to play a a
political game so that they can
understand how more people could be
educated about the political process I
mean there are great games like like
this I I remember um um interviewing uh
Henry in fact I believe
it may have been you Henry correct me if
I'm wrong but I remember um hearing
about a video game where a kid took the
video game into uh the school and the
video game was a a politically charged
video game a politically educational
video game about the electorial
college and when the kid who found out
and played the game by playing the game
ended up watching the news started
understanding why politicians were
making certain trips to certain States
and why they would stop and and maybe
even not just where they went but what
they're saying why they're saying it and
so it was really interesting because the
same kid that was playing this game then
watching television and and learning uh
took the game to school and was shut out
by a
teacher you know
so had he had a I don't know a magazine
about the same issue I mean I guess the
magazine or a book or you know any
other AC accepted piece of material
probably wouldn't have been fine and and
not even really knowing what the game is
about so there's this um uh you know
issue of of of that gatekeeper mentality
as well and so I think if I had this
land party I with Congress I would
certainly want them to play a game
number one that they can relate to and
then um hopefully be able to play a game
that would push their mind mentally as
to the possibilities of what what games
could do whether that's a pain
distraction game um that's being
developed at some of uh at the hos at um
uh with Breakaway games in Hunt Valley
Maryland with Mercy Hospital which is a
a pain distraction game for kids that
are going through procedures that are
uncomfortable and doctors are finding
better success rate because the kids are
playing these pain distraction games
that are Pleasant and keeps them relaxed
uh so I would want them to play things
that would uh take them out of just the
the the military con ceps and the
simulations but also kind of show them
the educational value in games and where
that could ultimately go and hopefully
get a few of them to understand what the
potential could
be Ian sticking with anything in which
he can frag his Congressman so yeah I'll
go to the next question still think
that's a good choice I have two I'm Joe
Beckman I do some Community organizing
in a couple communities around Boston I
have two very different questions the
first question is sort of I'll ask them
both and then you can deal with them in
any order you want
one is to take off of Henry's Point 12%
of the of the voters voted on
Tuesday is it an unfair Criterion to
measure the effect of Civic media in the
next five to 10 years to expect that
ratio to be
higher and how would that happen that's
the first question the second question
is why is there no game for school
evaluation there are standardized tests
but why not standardized interactive
measures which could be a game and could
be online why is it not
happened thank
you um well well there's the answer to
the second question is is twofold uh the
optimistic answer is that there are many
researchers in the learning Sciences
working on on methods of um uh
assessment for games that might lead to
such a thing sometime in the future
um the more pessimistic version is that
um um education is our educational
system is broken uh so I don't know that
we want to encourage uh such a thing
anyway um the answer to the first
question is I think yes and no
um and that that's all no
no um uh I think yes it's reasonable to
to imagine that we might look at
something like voter turnout um as a as
one aspect of of of of people's
engagement with uh uh uh with politics
and and and and and Civic life generally
whether we're talking about games or not
um but the problem I think has nothing
to do with games really is that voting
uh public uh that that kind of Civic
Service uh appears to people to be so
decoupled from the the policy decisions
that affect their lives that it's almost
um reasonable to imagine why they don't
bother and how can we how can we deal
with that fundamental problem instead of
the uh the problem of uh of the numbers
at the at the voting
booth yeah I can't hear you
either I I guess the question was even
if you deal with that second issue that
that you mentioned how would you
actually engage people in that process
then how would you get them to see that
well I mean that's I think I'd like to
think that's what I've been trying to do
in in my games about politics you know
to to demonstrate that the way that we
frame um uh public policy issues um is
broken so when we talk about when we
talk about um obesity and we talk about
it as a as an issue of self-control um
that uh that that has to do with um
people's uh activity or lack of it that
we we kind of cover over issues of of um
of um uh socioeconomic ics for for
example and and you know hopefully by
doing this um we ratchet up people's
demands and they make different demands
on uh on either they elected officials
or just the the ordinary people around
them um I mean it's certainly it's
certainly not a clear path from A to B
yeah yeah um I don't really have too too
much more to to add on to Ian other than
an example that I can look towards um
where in Baltimore for example they have
been talking about and have created an
an online space uh specifically for high
school kids that have an interest in
politics um so there's a little bit of a
difference there right because that
means we're already saying they have an
interest in it so I understand that but
even still um and what they started what
we started with uh mayor om Ali at first
was just these open uh chats that we
would have with uh with youth and
interfacing with government and
interfacing specifically with City Hall
on specific issues and I think they've
evolved that program now to it's it's
beyond ask the mayor um an issue they've
really harnessed that program now to
take these students that come from
various backgrounds throughout the city
and bring them into City Hall to really
uh Beyond a typical School tour uh to
expose them and actually put them to
work in their classes about issues that
the city council have actually dealt
with um um
which is is from the teacher response
that I've received has been interesting
in seeing the debate and the discussion
that these students are having um about
the political process so I don't know if
that's go if that's part of the answer
that will uh see more people want to
participate in in the political culture
but I think that's one thing that would
be would be looked at as a noted example
that's working well at least in
Baltimore anyway has voter participation
changed um
I wish I could say over no uh I
mean it's too no it it has I mean the
answer for that question is it hasn't
changed I mean we had low turnouts uh as
well so we don't know if that's the
answer yet but from the discussions that
we're hearing from students that that
don't care about politics versus the
students that are in this program uh and
even some of the students that didn't
think they needed to be in it but we're
kind of just like coaxed into it uh you
find that they're more engaged and at
least more aware of issues that are
happening
so um it has brought a little bit more
of a level of transparency uh to to how
government operates and I think that's
important I mean we took them into a
room uh inside of uh City Hall where we
call um uh gosh it's it's we don't call
it the war room it's
um that's what they call it that's it
feels like the war room um but it's a
it's a it's a um uh an opportunity where
all the agency heads of of the city come
before a a panel and and they do this uh
once a week and they have to uh pull up
their spreadsheets and it's total
transparency and so how many how many um
potholes were covered this week uh well
X didn't get done well well then why is
you're overtime so high if x potholes
weren't weren't covered and so when the
kids can actually see that this type of
dialogue and transparency and holding
people accountable was happening those
kids and and that was a ET of the main
group but those kids had a um more
engaging conversation and debate and
interest in watching the news and
understanding what people are saying um
and reading the paper and going to
online websites and participating so
whether or not that changes voter
turnout would be the hope but I think
that was a that's a good
start hello um I'm doing a project right
now where um I'm working with and it's
called a youth activism design Institute
and we're working with a bunch of young
people that already are incredibly
politically sophisticated running
political campaigns um doing youth
organizing and what we're trying to do
is have them use the game design lens to
reinvent their tactics around organizing
and I'm wondering what kind of um
experiences have you guys had in having
um or of helping young people think like
game designers um sort of getting young
people to understand second order
Dynamics um the magic circle like you
know the the Lexicon that game designers
have um have you what kind of
experiences have you had in sort of
lending that lens to people who already
are politically Savvy um and and and
what would you suggest we do or are
there any particular tools or techniques
you think we should be employing around
that
project I'm sorry can can you just
clarify the goal of the of the project a
little more basically uh we're we're
trying to so young people are doing good
work on the ground but they don't
necessarily always like the way they
approach on organizing sometime they
think it's dull sometimes they think
it's too much like the way adults do it
and they like games and they they're
interested in games but they want to try
to figure out how how do game designers
make their games fun like what are the
things they think about um so they're
interest you're interested specifically
in games about um new Mo new methods of
of organizing is that right no no it's
about that they understand organizing
yeah and game designers understand game
designers right and our premise is that
if young people understood what game
designers understand about design and
how how do you make systems that that
attract people and make them play
something for 120 hours maybe they could
do that to get people involved in
campaigns in ways that they can't right
now so we're trying to do that kind of
translation and I'm wondering have you
had any experience with that if you have
any suggestions for us around it make
sense that makes sense I think Mario
knows the
answer
I thought with I thought with your line
of questioning you you you had something
coming towards him um gosh I was ready
to uh I wasn't ready to go first I think
um
transparent I was I used my strategy on
you you did uh you gamed me uh and it
worked um let me see if I could take a a
a shot at this I I think what I think
what I understand your question to be is
a a great one number one because I think
it reminds me of the similar question
that we were asking of how do we use the
video game development process to tie
that to core academics um and so that
that brings you into what's the mindset
of the gamer or of the designer rather
and and and and what excites them and
you know but it's tough because you know
what you think excites them um may not
really be what they're working on at the
time I mean and I'm not to say that they
don't have a passion for working on the
game but the the game is is hot pizza
when when it starts out when you're in
that embryonic stage and you're having
discussions about the game and and
you're designing your thoughts and
you're putting it all out uh but after
six months it's the same pizza and it's
now cold pizza and so you bring up a
good point because how do you maintain
and you can speak to this I how do you
maintain your interest your energy and
your excitement with something that has
small steps that need to be that need to
uh have been taken in order to create a
big accomplishment and a bigger goal at
the end I you know for you I wonder if
um you might have to I'm gonna shift it
back I'm gonna game Ian I think on the
mental side I think on the mental side
Ian may have some ideas I'm assuming but
um I think from from from from tools
from tools that maybe you could use I
would certainly look at games that are
involved in exactly what you have these
youth invol D in I would I would
certainly I mean come see me after this
and and look at this game a force more
powerful this may um help help them
understand the design and the energy and
the fun that they put into this
particular game which is all about
accomplishing something of a common goal
which you're trying to do uh with these
kids and being that they're already
Savvy it's just a matter of getting them
around the right tools but you know one
of the things that you may also want to
look at are tools that are available
like Alice I mean or or maybe even to
step up from that like um uh personal
learning additions of uh of Autodesk um
the these are are software uh that are
out there but are available and maybe
you could uh excite your kids or excite
the youth to have them use the tools
learn about the tools to see if they can
come up with some ways of using the
tools to help them with their their
organizing or just make it more engaging
and fine but as it speaks to me the
mentality um you know it's hot pizza
when when it starts and then it's cold
pizza until it's time to release the
game and then it's hot pizza again so uh
I don't really know what goes on in
their mind throughout that process I
haven't studied that side of of of that
engagement I I I don't I admit that I
don't have a good answer uh which is why
I skirted the question um but but I do
want to note that um uh that Katie Salin
who was was here a couple weeks ago
right um and game lab and the University
of Wisconsin are working on a project
was funded by MacArthur to produce a a
game correct me here if I'm getting it
wrong um a game that would that would
actually enact some of the principles of
of game design itself and I'm not sure
what the calendar is for that but it's
approaching some kind of state of of
completion I think um so maybe keep keep
some keep an eye out for for that as
well yeah and maybe just speak maybe
speak to game designers as well I mean I
can help you with that defin don't
recommend speaking to game you
don't
but I can help I'm more than welcome
more than happy to try to point you to
some resources that would be open to
talking to you that are in that business
there are I mean it all serious there
are these books out there and there's
one even that's called like you know
game development for teens you know
which sounds oh that must be right you
know so it's definitely got the right
title uh this is uh this is a black art
um still uh for me and I don't I don't
know that uh that that there are are our
straight answers
anywhere hi Jean coup from the burkman
center for inter at Harvard and I work a
lot and I'm married to a lot of um I'm
married to only one person
but work lot this is an interesting
question
here
Ian so we made a game about that oh
yeah um community and Grassroots
organizers who are more often um very
skeptical a lot of different new ways of
doing things and and I remember going to
one office where there was a comic strip
on the on on pinned up on a cubicle with
two frames in in the first frame it has
uh kind of a church basement and there's
a there's a person who's saying oh
they're they're about to debate a new uh
law about abortion and then you have all
the people in the room like saying well
I'm I'm going to I'm going to you know
call on my friends and have them write
to their Senator and um you know I'm
going to basically go door too and get
people to to kind of do something about
this and you have the second frame and
they say well there's a there's a new
kind of uh law you know about uh kind of
also about abortion and and it's it's
like in a coffee shop and everyone's
like well I'm gonna do my interpretive
dance tomorrow about this and you know
I'm gonna I'm gonna do a film festival
about this issue and at the bottom of
the of the title for the comics trip is
you know why liberals lose um and you
can put aside the the you know the
ideological leaning of that particular
comic strip but um what I what some of
what I've been hearing about so far has
been how game media uh or a lot of this
kind of mass media in general can really
shape or change attitudes and I'm not
saying I completely agree with that
comic strip but there is a feeling of
well if you just make people aware of
things or more knowledgeable about
things or just put it in their face that
somehow magically something will happen
and and I'm curious if if you could
speak to basically is where you see the
mechanism between awareness of an issue
or being more knowledgeable about
something and then actually going and
doing something about it what's the
difference between U doing thetive dance
and making a phone call to your to your
Senator yeah that's a great question um
the when when someone says that's a
great question when you ask a question
they're not quite sure what to say next
U no the the in my experience working
with with um with all all groups on on
multiple sides of the of the political
Spectrum multiple parts of the political
Spectrum it's not so much about um
different strategies I mean everyone
goes door too and everyone puts out
media it's about the uh I think the the
risks that we take when we when we do
those things um so I've had a number of
of of games about um political topics
um effectively um you know censored into
Oblivion by by
democrats um and then um the the work
that I've done um with uh with
Republicans has has really been
interesting in in showing me um just how
how much uh more willing is kind of
ironic right they're supposed to be
conservative um how much more willing um
uh uh they are to accept a kind of
boldness of speech so I think part of it
is is honesty and uh and that that
doesn't have anything to do with um with
games again uh anymore although maybe
there's something we can we can get at
there but yeah this this framing problem
of sort of you know we'll go and we'll
talk about um you know uh uh uh an issue
among ourselves uh at the coffee shop uh
rather than go and muster uh you know
kind of strategic uh politically
strategic um strategies to to gain uh
voter share and that sort of thing um is
really a much bigger issue that I'm that
I'm prepared to answer on
here me
too
um my name is Rafi Santo I work with h
Global kids um so I've got a question
that's been on my mind for a while now
um in looking at the world of gaming and
those thinking critically about gaming
specifically about gaming and how it
relates to the social good I kind of see
two uh strains of thought one is the
games for change uh kind of Outlook and
one is the games and learning Outlook uh
and these really deal with two specific
uh different kinds of ideas about what
we're trying to teach one is about
attitudes and perspectives and one is
about skills and so you have um people
like James Paul G talking about games uh
like full spectrum warrior now it
teaches uh these incredible skills about
um you know what it means to embody the
discipline of a soldier and what it
means to uh embody you know all these
kinds of specific skills around
controlling teams uh and then you've got
on the other side kind of uh uh games
like uh Ian like you create that are
persuasive games news games uh games
with an agenda be it political or moral
social uh and they they're they're
basically uh coming from a perspective
that says we can through games convince
people uh to act in a different way and
so to me it actually looks like these
two two uh standpoints are at odds with
each other because uh if you take the uh
games and like persuasive games
perspective when you apply it to the the
first model where you've got these army
games you're basically saying okay so
we're teaching people to kill um and
something like America's Army actually
explicitly you know does that uh and on
the other side you're uh you're kind of
saying okay so with games that are
persuasive what kind of skills are they
actually learning you know so I'm
wondering if there's something that uh
might be on your minds that can Rectify
those two
worlds I'm happy to report there's a
chapter of my book about
this to which I might refer you I mean
the basic basic answer I gave is that um
both the uh the idea of of abstract
skills and the idea of of some kind of
of transfer of subject specificity are
are insufficient and um in fact what we
need is a kind of a tight coupling
between the um the mechanics of the game
and the and the the concept that it's
relating that that aboutness always
matters and we can't ignore it um and at
the same time once we admit that
something is potentially educational
then it might have other kinds of we
have to admit that there are these these
other possible outcomes that also occur
right so I I'm I'm not terribly bothered
by um the existence of both uh you know
military games and pacifist games they
just simply have different agendas at
work anything to add no I think I mean I
think um you know when you think about
games for Change and uh games for
learning um it's fortunately I don't
have to try to differentiate between the
two quite frankly uh I understand the
question and understand why that's
important and I think it um speaks to I
say I don't need to because uh I'm so
focused on the games for Learning and
for me for whatever
reason when we're dealing with the
students and the games for learning that
we're going through that is change um or
it is games for change in not in the
same definition that you subscri
describe but uh it it there is change
that's taking place so and a game is
responsible for that change I understand
it's not a specific agenda but there is
a specific agenda to what we want these
kids to get out of the program so um I I
do see this conflict if you will of that
question but I don't really see it
formulating itself through our students
I don't really see that happening in the
classroom what I do see with this
dilemma is and I you know I don't want
anyone to feel like their good work is
going on in drains but I think that I
just don't know that if we've reached a
point where we have the right
standardizations of the terminology for
what we're trying to do here and I think
part of that question brings up this
issue of of the language video game is
the is the right terminology is that the
term the right word no I mean that's
good to know I mean that's good to hear
is that is that the term that we should
say because the minute you say that term
to some people the the only the only way
the only way we make progress here is by
by investing some concept with meaning
that grows you know if we start
splintering um splintering off different
kinds of of topics into into whole
different you know genres of a medium
that have nothing to do with one another
then I think we lose the leverage that
we gain from from from the other aspects
so I'm I'm completely committed to that
well so let me ask one other question Ju
Just to you does is serious game
something we should stop
saying
yeah just wanted to make sure everyone
was clear thank you for that concise
answer part partially because um the the
our close is coming I'm going to take
one more question and partially because
Mario mentioned hot pizza recently and
it's gotten thinking ever since then so
so we're try to dra draw things to a
close we'll take one last question and
then allow some closing comments I'm
Michael skoler with American public
media and we've created um some
journalism games games are powerful in
that they're really good at teaching a
system so if you want to teach physics
as an educational game you can give
rules and then you let people apply them
they're also great at teaching a system
if almost implicitly you create a
situation you have someone live in it
and they learn the rules of the game
they learn what it takes to win and I
think that's what concerns me as we
Branch out into games for civic
engagement is that someone's writing the
rules into a game that basically is
implicitly teaching what it takes to win
and often the games that are persuasive
games advocacy games
um often teach a set of rules that that
are in someone's interest um and often I
think actually turn people off from
Civic engagement one classic example is
um games around elections in politics
that always have a little person warning
you that gee if you adopt this policy
you're going to get voted out of office
so what we're in implicitly teaching is
that the rules of the game are to act
like a politician we're not actually
teaching people without the issues for
example in that type of game and and
where you should come out on issues
based on what's going to improve Society
or the like and I guess I I rais this
more to get some thoughts as to trying
to create a fine line for a journalism
game that isn't advocacy what is really
about educating about attempting to
educate about the truth about the way
the world works but in a a way that
actually leaves um possibilities and
openness games inherently are kind of
closed systems where the rules get set
and everything you do kind of works
against the rules rules one thing I've
been thinking about and haven't quite
figured out how to do because the
complexity gets gets um uh gets high
very quickly is to have games that
actually have open answers where users
can actually create new scenarios
provide new information um about a game
as they go it's kind of akin to the Star
Trek you know uh movie where Captain
Kirk rewrote the rules of the game
because it was a game that had no way
out um and in some ways I think one of
the problems we have in media today with
Civic engagement and low voting rates is
that people in some way feel that the
rules of the game are such that there's
no way out people can't actually
influence politics anymore so I guess
I'm I'm asking some thoughts on whether
or not there's an inherent structural
problem in in Civic engagement gains and
that someone's got to write the rules
that kind of implicitly hold a view of
how Society
works this is the question we're going
to end on
yeah we'd end on a small throwaway
question
I guess I can't say yes won't work here
um yeah I mean there's an inherent um
conflict between politics and policy
forget about the games that are that's
just there so what you say about about
games about the political process I
completely agree with you know what you
learn is the uh what you learn is is is
campaigning you don't learn policy um
but I'm I'm I'm not sure that the answer
is is to open up um a system so that you
can do anything with it uh I think that
we have to we have to to learn and we
have to help other people learn that
just like any kind of artifact a game um
makes makes claims it has it has
opinions and those opinions are um built
into the rules into the processes that
are that are by which the game works and
we need to learn to read those and
understand oh gosh this is this is
actually where the arguments located
what is it trying to tell me about um
the way the world works or the way that
it might under someone's leadership or
so forth um now I don't know because all
of those things are very specific it's
going to be very very hard if not
impossible to design some some meta game
where all possible representations are
are available um and moreover I don't
want all possible representations I want
someone's um single representation of an
issue that they believe is right and
want to convince me of and then I want a
whole wealth of those that I can I can
kind of interact with and make decisions
between um hopefully leading me to make
real decisions um or or at least the uh
to to uh to facilitate others to make
those
decisions yeah my my two sents I think
on this are um one I I think uh I don't
know that I would want to play a totally
uh open-ended game either but I do
respect the idea of being able to
develop a game uh from my perspective
and I do think what we need to start
doing is letting more of um people that
play games be able to design scenarios
within those games now granted there
still are some rules about even just the
design of what you can do in a game so
it's still doesn't really solve the
answer to the scenario design right is
just going to ideologized the the
question of what what kind of options
are available right I mean so you're
you're kind of still back to square one
although you may have given someone the
idea or the perception that they're
really changing things um but I I think
on a bigger picture this kind of goes to
uh what I think is a problem in media um
and I think it's the diversity uh I mean
there's several issues with with this
question but I think one is if you felt
that news sources um were were more
demographically made up of the society
that you live in you would one could say
that the perspectives of that news
organization would be more uh
encompassing of its its communities that
it serves um and one could say the same
thing about a video game in other words
if you have a democratic process
throughout the design of a video game
and you allow people to challenge each
other with what the roles or the
outcomes or the challenges would be um I
think you you end up with something that
leads towards maybe where you would like
to go but doesn't ultimately solve uh
that that uh that question that you pose
but but I do think that that's a real
issue that needs to be addressed in the
industry when I talk to uh game
designers of different backgrounds and
you speak to them be outside of the
microphone or when the camera is turned
off and you have a a cordial upfront
discussion with them the the stories of
um you know some of the things that
happened in game development remind you
of uh some of the same things that
happen in other Industries but when you
hear about the the Shining Moments are
those where you find that true diversity
has been embraced by the company from
the top and that has really found itself
uh drilled down into the development of
the games um and to a larger library of
potential games uh because one thing's
for sure right we can't continue to just
um create uh Blockbuster titles I mean
that's that's a depth of the industry so
things like persuasive games right not
Blockbuster titles by the way
no but that's going that's going to
obvious that's clearly going to change
no that's going to change I I I firmly
my wallet when we're finished yeah stay
the course stay Ian stay the course I
firmly had to believe that that's going
to change um so I I mean I hope that
helps but also you know there you look
at Microsoft who's opened up um a little
bit right uh XNA is is a is a um a
platform if you haven't heard of it this
XNA platform is in theory supposed to
allow people uh that want to design to
be able to take components of games that
they play and be able to design upon
them and then maybe even offer them up
into uh the Xbox Live marketplace and
what's interesting is you start seeing
games that are not like what you would
expect you start seeing games about
issues and about things that are being
discussed in the news um uh so so I you
know that doesn't fully answer your
question but I think that gives you an
understanding of at least where I'm
seeing some things and I think as long
as is your is your Newsroom diverse
we're working on it but those are
terrific answers thank you thank you
yeah I think it starts there for me I'll
offer an opportunity I know we've run
over all of an opportunity for the for
the speakers to have one minute to any
final
thoughts I want to meet Ian's
kid 5-year-old genius here
um so I I mean you know the the just
just to summarize um some of the ideas
the I think the important thing to
realize with respect to games and and
and Civic engagement is that this is
actually a very different kind of
computer medium than the sort that we've
been discussing primarily in um in in
this kind of conversation or in the in
the broader um uh uh public discourse
which is stuff like um you know websites
and and and and and social networks and
and these sorts of things blogs um
there's something fundamentally
different about about video games and
the way that they represent what they do
with the computer uh and their potential
is is uh considerably
untapped um so I just want to draw
attention to that as as a kind of
closing um uh comment that there's
there's something that that can be done
here that hasn't yet and it's something
that uh that I think takes advantage of
of computers um in a way that uh that
other kinds of media haven't so now
maybe it's time to uh to to to do some
catch
up yeah um I I you know I think in
closing I think um you so much that my
mind is racing to want to want to try to
squeeze in right to to to close out with
but I think as as it relates to the
theme of tonight's discussion
um we see a society where um access to
technology is becoming more prevalent um
we're seeing a society where Broadband
connections make the speed of
communication that much faster we're
seeing a a mobile Society that's
becoming Wireless and um you know when I
walk around now and see uh kids that are
just were just learning computers a year
ago now telling me Mr Armstrong you know
I know how to get RSS feeds um that that
tells me something about um their
propensity their potential and their
understanding of Technology as it
equates to information and when exposed
correctly as that information can equate
to influence and empower for them to
make decisions I think video games this
meeting um filled with so many great
questions have some some answers uh that
just aren't there because it's they need
to be done they need to be developed it
needs to be researched and this is a
great exposure of the opportunity of
what the medium of video games has to
offer uh Civic engagement I go back to
the one story when I asked a kid and I
challenge any of you when you leave here
tonight go and ask ask kids you don't
talk to ask someone at the at the at the
line at a a uh restaurant ask them uh
when you're at the gas station ask them
in public places if you were to create a
game what would that game be and if you
actually take notes as to what some of
these kids uh Dressed in various ways
from various backgrounds uh had to say I
think many of you might be as shocked as
I was and optimistic about where things
could go if the education and exposure
could get to them at a level and at an
age where they're willing to accept it
and be influenced by it I'm speaking of
Middle School primarily um so I think
that's where I would like to to leave
it so I'd like to thank our speakers um
and of course the communications forum
the center for future Civic media and
the night foundation for their support
and hopefully the pizza has not gotten
cold since we' run a few minutes over
but hopefully not don't blame me and
thank you for a lot of great questions
yeah really it's great time thank
you